Ucrania amaneció bajo una nueva oleada
de ataques
misiles y aviones no tripulados causaron
pánico durante la madrugada de este 8 de
mayo en varias localidades las
autoridades aseguraron que derribaron al
menos 35 drones de fabricación iraní en
kiev y se reportaron daños importantes a
infraestructuras civiles
hemos estado en guerra Durante un año
todavía da miedo pero no tanto como en
el principio Pero por supuesto da miedo
Es horrible sobre todo para los niños
anoche los recogí y los llevé a casa
antes del toque de queda y a las 2 a.m
comenzaron los sonidos los ataques
fueron lanzados en vísperas de la
conmemoración en Rusia del día de la
Victoria fecha que recuerda el triunfo
del ejército rojo sobre la Alemania nazi
otras ofensivas fueron reportadas en
harquive gerson nikolife y Odessa donde
la Cruz Roja aseguró que uno de sus
almacenes donde guardaba material
humanitario fue destruido por la caída
de un misil Ruso
Mientras que el líder del grupo de
mercenarios Wagner aseguró que sus
hombres siguen avanzando en bakmut
mientras esperan municiones prometidas
por el kremlin
hasta el día de hoy Wagner ha avanzado
hasta 280 metros en diferentes
direcciones hemos avanzado hasta 53.000
metros en total quedan unos 2,37
kilómetros cuadrados bajo el control del
enemigo estamos avanzando esperando
recibir municiones
por otro lado kiev denunció que Moscú
paralizó el acuerdo de granos del mar
Negro al detener buques ucranianos en
aguas turcas el acuerdo vence el 18 de
mayo y Rusia ha amenazado con
abandonarlo